[FOREIGN] California.
Hello, and welcome to our webcast,
Germany, Austria, Switzerland, Stanford
Graduate School of Business and beyond.
My name is Tim Eisenmann, and I'm a second
year MBA student here at the GSB.
I am very proud to be graduating in
just a couple of weeks, also a bit sad.
I'm joined by Desiree Peill and
Dominik Facher.
Like me, they are from Germany.
They are first year MBA students and
will graduate in 2016.
We'll be talking about the student
experience here on campus and
answer as many of your questions as we
can, including those submitted in advance.
We won't be talking about the admissions
process, the application, or
financial aid.
You can find these answers
on the Stanford MBA website.
To submit a question to us about
what it's like to be a student,
just click the Chat icon
at the top of your screen,
enter your question in the Chat window,
and click Send to All in your screen.
To kick us off, I'd suggest that maybe
we introduce ourselves a little bit,
so you know who you'll
be hearing from today.
Desiree, would you like to kick us off?
>> Sure.
My name is Desiree.
I'm an MBA1 student here at the GSB.
Prior to the GSB, I worked in
consulting with a focus on media.
I did my undergrad in Switzerland, in
[FOREIGN], and after that worked a lot for
various media companies as a journalist
and then later on the business side.
And I'm very happy to be here at the GSB
and excited to talk to you about it today.
>> Thanks.
Yeah, so I'm Dominik,
originally from Munich.
I grew up a little bit outside the city,
so all countryside, mountains, outdoors.
That's what I enjoyed
during the youth time.
And, yeah, when you're not outside and
you're in the countryside,
the first thing that comes to mind
when you don't do that is computers.
So, I always was very
attached to technology.
I studied Computer Science as a result of
that, studied in Munich and in Zurich.
And after that, we started
a company in the field of, yeah,
recruiting social networks, so
I worked as a software engineer there.
And after we finished
up with that company,
I worked in consulting as well,
mainly in the technology space.
And, yeah,
now I'm here at the GSB as well.
>> As I said already, my name is Tim.
I'm from Frankfurt originally.
I used to work in transportation for
Lufthansa, one of the big
German companies.
[LAUGH]
>> And in corporate strategy for two and
a half years.
Then did a lot of transportation
focus here at the GSB.
We found a class that was present
at the travel hospitality club and
also did a little bit of work in
the social impact sector in Africa,
two very different things, and post GSB,
I'll be doing consulting in the outland
transportation sector as well.
Well, it's, maybe,
get a head start and go and
answer one of the questions
that were submitted in advance.
Why did you guys apply to Stanford?
[LAUGH] Or business school in general?
What were the driving factors,
and why Stanford in particular?
Maybe Dominik, do you wanna start?
>> Yeah, sure.
Yeah, I mean, for
me it's basically the place to be, right?
So I wanted to be in the Silicon Valley
cuz this place is really where
sort of the future gets built.
This is where all the big companies, all
the ideas come together, and Stanford, for
me, was sort of really
central in that ecosystem.
And I think it's a very special place
in that sense that you find in very few
business schools, if any, actually.
So that was a key driver for me, and
besides that, I was always sort of
torn to that technology part of it so
that made it sort of an easy choice for
me to chose Stanford as a business school.
And then you asked sort of why
business school in general, so for
me it was always I come very much from
the technology and engineering side, and
then at some point realized that sorta
there's a business side as well to it.
I learned a little bit of
that in consulting, but
essentially, I saw the very small
companies when they get started, and
I saw the really big companies.
It's like the really, really big ones,
but I never saw this place in between.
And so for me, it was always how does this
go from really small to scaling it pretty
big, and part of that is
actually scaling yourself, right?
So how can you scale yourself as in
you have a team of three people, and
then suddenly you're a thousand people or
even more.
>> Yeah.
>> How can you manage that, and
a lot of that is personal skills,
leadership skills, etc.
And this for me was sort of the main
driver for business school in general.
>> Mm-hm.
How about you, Desiree?
>> So why [COUGH] I chose to
apply to business school.
I feel like after three years
in consulting I just felt
like a [FOREIGN] after some time-
>> [LAUGH]
>> Where you just focus on one specific
topic, get pretty good at it, but it's,
you kind of miss a broader horizon.
And I felt that, in particular,
Stanford would offer that the most to me.
In particular, looking at the ecosystem
here, the same you talked about,
it feels like a little bit,
I think like Florence must have felt like
that in the Renaissance where everything
is happening exactly in this little,
tiny piece of land, and
it's just exciting to be here.
And then, more specifically for
me, in media and journalism,
it's a hugely disruptive, the industry
is hugely disrupted at the moment,
by a lot of the things which are going on
here, and so I was just very excited to
learn about it and
to know more of what is going on there.
>> It does take a little bit of, well,
convincing and telling other people
though because business school isn't that
commonly known as
a career path in Germany.
In the US, it's a bit different.
>> Yeah.
>> But
it does bring us closer to our goals.
Or at least, when I speak for myself.
Maybe we can add onto what you said
Desiree about being here in an ecosystem
of entrepreneurship while having
a very strong background in media.
How has the GSB helped you get closer
to want you want to do after Stanford?
>> So kinda coming here, I knew that there
is the Arts Media Entertainment Club,
for example,
which I am the president of right now.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] Which is doing a lot of things
in this school, kind of bringing
me to executive hear talking,
bringing companies here to talk about
what's going on in the industry.
And furthermore, there are a bunch
of classes which are kind of hugely
tailored to exactly that space.
So there's one about leadership and
entertainment.
I'm taking another one actually not at the
business school but on campus in Stanford,
which is called Entrepreneurial Media.
And so we are kind of in that class
already, working in teams and
working on business ideas and pitching
it to investors this Friday actually and
trying to figure out whether we have
found something, which is interesting.
And so overall,
I think the GSB is helping me also,
personally, to look at all
these different spaces.
It's very easy to actually contact
people and get them to talk to you
about these things, and so it's been kind
of from clubs, from the classes, but
then also from people who come to
the GSB and talk to me about the topic.
>> And the @standford.edu email address
opens any door you want to have opened.
>> Yeah, that's true.
>> And Dominik is casually starting
his own company right on campus.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Maybe you can speak
about that a little.
>> Yeah, sure.
And also,
I fully agree with what Desiree said.
For me, it was never really
a traditional career path post GSB, so
I never had that in mind.
And there's a lot of
classmates who have that.
If, for example, if you go into banking,
etc., it's a very clear path.
And that, for me, was never the case and
not part of making the decision
towards going to business school, but
it's all those other elements
that come together, and I think.
It makes a key difference from the GSP, so
first of all there's the network you get
right, the access you get to people.
So for example, I'm in a class
with Peter Levine right now,
who's the enterprise software partner
from Andreessen Horowitz, which is,
it's probably the best VC that
you can find out there, right?
And so you really have access and very
close connections in those people, and
it's really tremendous.
And as Tim said, we're sort of starting
our own business right now, and yeah if
you have access to those people and really
can have a casual chat with them, and
ask them certain questions that you have.
It just makes a huge difference right, and
this is sort of the thing then you get
the introduction, and
then you get the next step, and
most of the stuff that you actually try
to do, you're right at the center of
where your customers are,
where the ideas get sparked.
You get all this inspiration
from other schools.
It's just a five minute walk and
your in Computer Science,
which is probably also the best
Computer Science Department in the world.
So it's really, it all comes together
in this a weird thing of ecosystem,
and in the non traditional career path,
I think this is what makes the difference,
that you have access to all of those
opportunities and just can go into it.
>> One thing I just wanna add is,
that even if you have a very
particular interest, such as
>> Yeah
>> media, I know a couple of people that
are in bio tech.
The GSB does offer a lot of classes
already but then, across the street and
basically all the other faculties,
Stanford GSB students can
take classes as well.
So there are a couple of classmates
that have only taken the minimum of GSB
classes, and taken advantage of
all the across the street classes.
>> Yeah.
>> A lot of people take the base coding
class, just so they know how to
speak with technical co founders.
>> Yeah.
>> Let's maybe
pivot to some of the questions
that were submitted right now.
How has the different education style,
US versus German speaking
countries played out for you guys?
What were the major differences?
>> So I think, for me, even though
I studied at a small university,
classes were still massively huge,
so here we have classes
from 20 to 70 people and it's-
>> Or even smaller, in lead lab's 12.
>> yeah, 12's true.
And it's, it's fascinating because you-
>> I think it's more than 12-
>> Four actually.
>> yeah.
>> Sorry it was a year ago.
>> And it's fascinating to have kind of
everybody participating a lot more and
that's also something
you have to get used to.
It's kind of much more, interactive.
People are expecting to speak up.
It's slightly different
than back where I studied.
But then also, I think we've
been kind of educated to not be
as controversial when we kind of make
statements, and things like that.
The discussions don't come up that easily,
but this is entirely different here,
and people just speak their minds, and
there's always an interesting
discussion going on in the classroom.
>> Yeah let's, so
Larry have you talked about how you
make the most out of what's
happening on campus.
i mean there are so many activities,
what do you prioritize,
was it overwhelming at first, and
how have you managed to do now?
>> Definitely overwhelming.
The thing is you can do
whatever you want right.
So if you're curious about things.
There's everything going on, and so
one of the things for me coming in was to
sometimes not do the smart things,
but the sort of more interesting and
curiosity driven things, and
you can do whatever you want basically.
So if there is a session on virtual
reality, you just learn more about virtual
reality, or all those crazy things that
are going on, and sort of the edges that
often times you don't have access to when
you're not in the university context.
And so, this is sort of the curiosity part
for me, and the other part with resources,
when you think about actually
a business and starting something,
there's tremendous resources available
from events to personal coaching's
to sort of classes where you can actually
learn those things directly, and
you get mentors that help you etc.
And yeah, so at the end of the day,
I remember when we started you
basically leave your home at eight o'clock
and then you come back at ten o'clock.
You were like busy the whole day,
for me it was more busy then
during when I was working
>> That means Dominique does not
go out and party, so if he comes home
at ten am [INAUDIBLE] [CROSSTALK].
>> That’s right
>> He's a boring software engineer.
>> Yeah, but that's about it.
You go to bed, maybe you party,
maybe you don't.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But you go to bed, and
it's this happy sort of stress, right?
>> Yeah.
>> You just feel like there was so
much going on, and you feel exhausted, but
at the same time, it's a good sort of
exhaustion, and yeah and sometimes you
need to prioritize, but my thing was
always to keep more the filter open, and
take in as much as possible,
rather than the other way around.
>> I would totally agree with
that in particular this idea that
you kind of just get everything,
kind of bombarded at you, but
on the other hand it's your own stress.
So priority and consulting is always
like a partner in giving you stress, or
the client giving you stress,
but right now it's all about you,
and you can decide everything and
it's incredibly energizing as well.
>> Yeah that's right.
>> One of the question that just came
in asked about the background of your
classmates.
Well a whole bunch of them
are internationals just like us.
There are of course a lot of classmates.
>> [COUGH]
>> From South America,
a lot from Asia, Central Europe as well,
I think in my class we had a lot of
Germans, French, Spanish students, but
it varies I mean there is no set amount of
people that come from a specific country.
It really depends on the application
pool of that specific year.
But maybe you can talk about some
classmates that have been especially
inspiring and have had a really
interesting professional background.
>> Sure.
So I think for me, we have musical stars,
people who were on American Idol for
example,
and they have the most beautiful voices,
and incredible artistic talent, which is,
we have a big show every year,
where people kind
of produce a one time musical, and it's as
professional as you would see on Broadway.
That was something that I didn't
even expect coming here, and
I was incredibly impressed.
Then right now I just come out of
a classroom where somebody talked
about their operations experience
at Formula One, and how he for
seven years worked as a manager and
general manager in the Middle East for
the Formula One team of thank you.
[LAUGH] I'm a huge Formula One
fan obviously, but
it's just entirely different
than a lot of others.
I think I can think of like more and more.
Do you have some more?
>> Yeah I mean same, and for
me what was pretty interesting was talking
to people who were in the military before,
which is something that was really not
present whatsoever before in
sort of the European education.
And really hearing how they
experienced their lives before and
whatever happened, and
you can hardly imagine.
It just gives you a lot of perspective,
right?
And that happens to all different sorts
of people, like I don't know, we have
professional poker players, whatever, it's
really interesting, and essentially it's
different perspectives on things you had
in mind before, and you just challenge it.
>> And maybe just to give,
so we have each week,
we have two classmates actually
sharing their story and
sharing their entire lives
with us in a 30 minute talk.
That's every Monday for the MBA1s and
every Wednesday for the MBA2s, and
it's kind of that's the moment where
you get to know them, and you know so
much more about where they come from,
the life they've been living before, what
has shaped them, who they are today, and
it's kind of a very inspiring
to actually get to know people.
>> First, it's a lot of, hey,
what have you been doing?
Where are you from?
>> Yes.
>> What did you do before hand?
And then the GSB I think finds
good ways to connect people-
>> That's true.
>> In smaller more meaningful settings.
Talk is one of them.
But there are tons of small group
dinners that are actually supported by
the university financially.
There are wind groups where women come
together and talk about their experience
in maybe more male-dominated
environments or at business school.
And then, of course, the clubs,
as you've mentioned,
does host a variety of events with
people that have a similar interest.
So they get to know each
other on a deeper level.
>> Yes.
>> And then all the outside stuff,
like I've actually gotten to
know more people playing tennis-
>> [LAUGH]
>> Than with any other thing at the GSB.
>> I mean, beyond that, I think It's
not just those kinds of events but
also that the class size is
smaller in general, right?
So, yeah, I mean,
we're 400 people roughly?
>> Yeah, I think so.
>> [LAUGH]
>> For me it was something that you can
actually get to know 400
people quite well, right?
Versus if it would be 1000 or more people,
I'm not sure I could get to know each and
everyone in that sense.
And you always have this moment of where
you actually wanna get to know everyone
and hear those stories whatsoever.
And I think 400 people is the size
where you have enough interaction on
a regular basis.
>> Yeah.
>> So that works.
>> So let's dial back for you guys,
probably a year and a half.
You were thinking about
applying to business school.
How did you know that
that was the right time?
>> Good question.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Was it the right time?
>> For
me there was no such question actually.
I didn't particularly design this
process of now it's the time to apply.
So it never crossed my mind in that sense.
I always had this notion in mind
that I need to sort of get back.
I need the time to sort of
develop those more leadership,
more long-term oriented skills, especially
from an empathy, people perspective.
And I think business school
is a good place to do that.
And especially the focus that the GSB
gives on sorta this empathetic leadership
and leadership development.
I think is a good thing about that.
And it just felt right in terms
of I want to do the next step.
But I never specifically designed
a timeline where I knew it was right.
So, yeah.
>> What about for you?
Because I think for us we had a more
traditional kind of consulting path,
and it's kind of suggested to you,
but you decided that.
>> So I was very fed up with my job.
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> I learned a ton, and
I had great colleagues, but it was a very
hierarchical German corporate environment.
And I was basically told I'm doing
a great job, but in order to take on more
responsibility, I have to do
the same job for another five years.
Maybe with a different title but
basically the same thing.
And there were a bunch of options on
the table, either changing jobs or
going to business school.
I decided that I would give it a shot,
Harvard or Stanford,
because I figured that if I spent that
much money, I might as well do it on
one of those schools that have a huge,
grand recognition.
And that worked out well, and
then I figured I would come and do it.
So, similar to Dominik,
I hadn't mapped it out.
Had it not worked,
I might have spent another year at my job.
I might have gone to
a different business school.
But I did not have the five year plan.
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> So let's move to another question from
the audience.
That's actually an interesting one.
So how has the Stanford experience been
different to what you guys expected?
Is there anything you did not come see,
besides the fact that there are opera and
musical stars in the class?
>> [LAUGH] I think for me,
what has surprised me is that how much
kind of social activity there is.
So for me, I think I'm an introvert
by nature, and just like coming here,
and the way, how much there is and
how much there is to experience and
how much energy that actually
takes was new to me.
So I've never, I think I've never
experienced as many dinners,
as many parties, as many every things,
and so it's kind of a very
intense environment, not only from
a kinda school perspective and
everything else just going on in
your mind, but also just socially.
And it's a happy surprise
because it's wonderful.
But it also takes enough energy and kinda
brain space to think a lot of how all of
this sorta productivity
kinda comes together.
>> Yeah, yeah, agree.
>> [LAUGH]
>> That's definitely,
what was surprising for me is,
we talked about it before, right,
that it actually rains in California.
>> [LAUGH]
>> They don't tell you that before.
>> Well, twice a year.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And
those two days have been the last two.
No, actually it has been fairly good.
I was actually surprised
how cool people are.
Because when you think
about business school,
you think of that as being one of the
puzzle pieces in your professional life.
But I think also in the personal life,
it has shaped me a lot because it gives
you two years to breathe,
take a step back,
look at what you've done, look at who you
are, and look at what you wanna do after.
And I thought it would be a way to
acquire some more tools in order to be
a better manager.
But I think the introspection,
the level of self-reflection, and
the time I have for that-
>> That's true.
>> Was pretty impressive.
And one class in particular that we have
to basically talk about is touchy feely,
interpersonal dynamics.
Desiree has taken it.
Dominik, not yet.
>> Not yet.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So he does not know what we're talking
about.
What it basically is, is,
I think, 12 people or 16 people?
>> Yeah, 12.
>> 12 people in a room without
instructions, a script, anything.
Two facilitators but basically 12
people sitting next to each other and
having nothing to talk about.
And then you start talking about things.
For example, I might ask, Desiree,
hey, should we talk about norms and
when to arrive for class?
And then Desiree might tell me, well,
Tim, by you asking that question,
you implicitly took on a leadership
role in this class and-
>> Which I'm not comfortable with.
>> I don't feel comfortable with that.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And you get feedback on your actions,
live, and in way you usually don't
get it in a work environment.
>> Yeah, that actually speaks to one
of the questions around kinda how to
develop your soft skills and know more
about your strengths and weaknesses.
And it's phenomenal.
So I'm just in the last-
>> You
said you fell in love with the class.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I have my last class tomorrow where we
share the final feedback which is
basically five hours of feedback
to 12 people in a room.
And its only one kind
of small piece of it.
in general, we spend a lot of time during
night class sitting around together and
just learning about each other, learning
what actually works, what doesn't,
what works for you,
how do you react to things.
You just get a lot more self-aware and
know what works for you, but
you also learn a lot about how other
people interact and kind of trying to
hone your skills of how to actually
work in groups and how that works.
So I thought it was a phenomenal
experience when it comes to soft skills.
But there are also a lot of others,
so maybe you want to do leadership?
>> Yeah, and I think in general,
even beyond that, that's just one element.
But what was surprising for
me is how deliberately the GSB
actually shapes culture, right?
And you spend a lot of time talking about
norms and how people interact together,
and all of those different sessions and
courses come together, and
you sort of develop a culture.
And for me it was really surprising to
see that it's almost like you engineer
a certain culture, right, and this
openness, vulnerability, feedback, etc.
>> Yeah.
It feels almost like a DNA of the GSB.
And we've been though the first year, and
then now it seems like, almost, we sort
of, got that DNA, and feel comfortable
with it, and sort of live it ourselves.
And I think that's, yeah.
>> Yeah, I was almost worried to go
back to the real world and experience,
everybody's not as vulnerable, and open,
and sharing, and caring as we are here.
>> No I think it's a very
special environment here.
And there's certain things you can
take back into the real world,
and some things you might want to keep for
yourself.
Talking about the real world.
What are you guys going
to do over the summer?
Maybe you could talk about the recruiting
process for summer internships.
Where are you guys going to
head out in like two weeks.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> I'm just going to stay here.
>> I'm going to stay here so I cannot
talk to much about recruiting process.
Maybe you can add a little bit after that.
But yeah we're using the summer in this
very specific three month period to
actually start a business
in insurance space.
So we're trying to use technology and
insurance, and
build something around that.
And, yeah.
I think it sort of felt like the first
year, for me, was taking a step back.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Learning a lot of new things.
But also building out a team to do that,
right?
And so one of the team members,
actually, from the GSB.
Right now, it's on this whole
ramping up period for that.
So instead of recruiting,
we did a business plan and
what service you can
probably substitute that.
For the summer,
I'm actually staying here in Paulo Alto
also, and we're starting a business here.
>> So I maybe took a more
traditional recruiting path.
There are a bunch of on
campus recruiting events.
Companies coming to campus, and
talking about their recruiting process and
then starting that process.
Mainly big corporates from the US,
some from Europe, consulting companies,
finance companies.
That is the on campus recruiting.
Then there is it's like
a smaller SNP recruiting.
One of the key events at the GSB
is the fewer than 300 event for
companies that have less than
300 employees come to campus.
And it's very informal casual setting,
and you get to talk to up and coming
companies, even PRIDE, and those kind of
companies, usually tech in the valley.
And then there is networking
based recruiting.
So you can meet with
Career Management employees,
and they help you kind of find people that
work in the space that you wanna be in,
and can connect you directly.
Given that the class size is fairly small
with 400, the community is very strong.
So even if people 20 years
before you graduate,
are now in an interesting position.
They will usually return your email, or
your call, and get back back to you.
I see we are almost running out of time,
that went by quickly.
With four more minutes to go,
before we go, Dominic, Desiree,
any words of final advice for the people
that are thinking about applying
to Standford, and
your GSB highlight in year number one?
Ladies first I guess.
>> In terms of advice,
I would say fight through the application
process, and the GMAT, and all that.
Is a lot of work and
it's kind of stressful.
And especially for me,
it was a stressful period doing
that kind of next to your job.
But it's incredibly worth it.
And this time here has been one of
the most amazing of my life and so
I'm incredibly.
Thankful and I just want to
tell you that it's going to be,
coming out of this whole process you're
gonna be here and it's wonderful.
What's the most amazing moment for me?
I think there have been a few ones.
>> You can have only one.
>> [LAUGH]
>> All right.
Maybe you can think of one.
>> I'll think about it.
>> Maybe you'll come up with one, perhaps.
Dominic?
>> Yeah, same here.
I think just do it is
probably a good way to, yeah.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yeah.
I think, people tell you that the
application process itself is valuable.
For me, back then it was sort of,
I couldn't believe that, but actually is,
in a certain way.
Cuz it forces you to reflect yourself.
Forces you to engage also the people you
ask for a recommendation on a very, sort
of, deeper feedback conversation, and,
sort of, get all of those things together.
So I think just do it,
is probably the right thing for me to say.
And when it comes to a favorite moment,
it's hard to pinpoint.
Cuz there's actually so much happening.
It feels like one day of GSB is
probably like a week of normal life.
>> It's like with dogs, one year's like
two year, three human lives or something.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yeah.
But I think what was really
cool experience in general is
stuff with the GST what we do here.
So we have to do this, global study trips.
I took the global route
to the US actually.
[LAUGH] But it's sort of this
study trip where you actually
get to know a country deeper and better.
And you're in a group of 20,
30 people roughly.
You have a lot of meetings
with professionals,
with politicians, industry leaders
together, sort of the culture.
But you also get to know
your peers really well.
I think this GST experience for
me was pretty cool.
I mean we had phenomenal meetings.
We've been to New York, for example,
where we met Micheal Bloomberg.
And you have a pretty intense and
open discussion with those people and
for me this was cool.
>> Mm hm.
>> it was a pretty cool experience.
>> My piece of advice be yourself.
Really show case what makes you different,
and don't talk about you know,
what makes you similar to a lot of
people that might have gone to the GSP.
The class aims to be as
diverse as possible.
So whatever makes you special should
definitely be in the application.
And my highlight was, in my first year,
I had been working in Rwanda.
And I had the change to have lunch with
Paul Kagame, the President of Rwanda.
>> Right.
>> Which was really interesting.
Getting to speak to a person
like that one on one.
And I think that's basically it.
Thank you so much Desiree and
Dominic for joining us this morning, and
thanks to all of you for participating.
If you'd like to hear more about the GSB,
you can meet an MBA admissions officer in
person while they travel to many
cities throughout Europe this summer.
I believe Germany, Austria and
Switzerland, are probably
amongst their route.
Please keep an eye out for
the invitations to meet them, or
check the events page on
the Stanford MBA website.
You can also learn more about the MBA
program, admission requirements, and
financial aid on the website.
Application for the class starting in the
fall of 2016 will be available in June.
Finally, please take a moment to answer a
few survey questions about your experience
with us today.
Once the webcast ends, click the Ok
button on the pop up window, and
you'll be redirected
automatically to the survey.
Thanks again, have a great day, [FOREIGN].